it's the biggest challenge that mankind  has ever taken on  [Music]  we need bold solutions across many areas  to succeed  as a scientist i have confidence that we  can develop the technologies  it's the world's greatest opportunity  for innovation  [Music]  can we do it yes it all starts with  accepting that we need a paradigm shift  technologies by themselves  are not going to be the ones that are  going to solve this problem we need them  but we need to combine them with the  social the environmental the ecological  dimension  [Music]  i'm an optimist because i know what  technology can accomplish and because i  know what people can accomplish there's  a lot of progress that's being made and  if you could just understand how far  we've come you would be optimistic too  we need to now accelerate that change  i believe if there's a will there is a  way